Le serial mythos c'est des mecs ou des meufs
Qui racontent à tout le monde des trucs qui ont jamais fait
En permanence
Un serial mytho ça peut pas mentir
Sur un mensonge trop clair et net
Comme par exemple...
"Bonjour,
je suis Robbie Williams ;)"
Ca c'est pas possible parce que c'est vérifiable dans le présent, tout de suite.
Mais le problème c'est que pour pas les vexer on est obligés de faire semblant de les croire
"Mon grand cousin il a une jaguar et des fois il m'la prête
genre la dernière fois il me l'a prêté, je suis allé sur l'autoroute et j'ai eu un accident
et la voiture elle a fait des tonneaux et tout..."
"Ah ouais ?
d'accord... et heu... ouah ! t'es pas blessé quand même un peu parce que heu...
normalement ça tue des gens des trucs comme ça..."
"Bah non parce que si tu veux dans les jaguar t'as des.. airbags et tout euh de sport..."
Quand tu cherches la petite bête et que t'essaye de leur prouver que ce qu'ils disent il est complètement faux, ils utilisent un technique euh très spéciale...
"Moi une fois avec ma sœur pour se marrer on a avalé du plomb"
"Bah non regarde, si tu avales du plombs tu meure directement, comme le prouve précisément ce livre de sciences breveté par la NASA
"heu..."
la technique du "je sais plus trop"
"Attends... ah non, en fait c'était pas du plomb je crois. c'était un autre métal... ou je sais plus trop... enfin bon on s'en fout on change de sujet
allez !"
what is the fuck ?
le pire c'est que c'est souvent quand toi tu racontes un truc vrai qui t'es vraiment arrivé que ça leur donne envie de surenchérir sur un mytho
pour être encore plus fort que toi
"Moi j'ai un pote qui parles bien anglais et qui en plus se démerde pas mal en espagnol"
"Ah ouais ? Bah moi ça me fait penser, justement,
j'ai un pote, lui, il parle carrément neuf langues..."
Comme par hasard !
Des fois je me demande comment ça ferais deux mythos qui se rencontrent et qui discutent
"Bah moi ma sœur elle parle heu... vingt et une langues !"
"Ah ouais ? et ben moi quand j'ai fait l'armée, y avait un mec qui parlait vingt-huit MILLIARD de langues
en même temps!"
pfff...
Ca sert à rien, les sérial mythos, ils auront toujours le dernier mot !
"Ouais s'tu veux moi j'ai bossé au States pendant un an en tant que directeur de projet photo...
"Ah ouais, c'est bizarre parce que maintenant tu travailles en tant que stagiaire..dans les magasins Shopi"
Ouais, mais si tu veux, au States, ça a aucun rapport, ça a aucun rapport avec la France, parce que les métiers, c'est pas la même échelle,
"Moi quand j'étais petit, j'avais un QI de 253 je crois, j'étais genre surdoué et puis depuis j'ai tout perdu, maintenant je suis redevenu normal."
FAUX !
Abonne toi à ma chaine youtube
En cliquant ici...
Et tentes ta chance pour peut-être gagner...
...Le détecteur de mensonge de macgyver
Du balai les serial mythos !
C'est pas un balai ça..
Bah c'est une sorte de balais quoi hein...